Okay, we are back live.
Hi. Getting a bit of a late start
today.
Um, the goal is to just focus
for a few
hours and just really hammer out the
rest of these environment fixes.
Um, I bet I want to hammer out the rest
of these environment fixes. I want
to probably set up containers, fix some
experiments, and then just start running
some
stuff over to here.
recall, we did kind of have mobile
working. I got this working last
Oh, well, this is just not running the
uh the correct code at all, huh?
[Music]
code. Maybe neural MMO
3. Now, this doesn't have a shared
either.
this
maps. Oh, you know what? This can
actually get veinated, can't it?
We got no
maps. All these rewards
Okay. So, seg
fault we have uh we have prepared for
this
This is what we
want. And
trace. Probably something in the binding
file, right?
Hey YouTube
folks, we're going to finish here. The
um so apparently I I forgot I did this,
but last night I must have just fixed
MOA. Um tower climb I have a couple
things remaining to fix on and then we
will probably do all the
containerization work today. Uh, that's
probably something I can I can mostly
get
done. That actually means that once I
ship those, you all will be able to test
all this stuff out super easily. So, if
anybody wants to come help test release,
helps us out a bunch. Kind of just use
it, play with it, see what things work
and what things don't, and like tell us
what's
Yeah. So, this is uh I just did this
like dict unpacking
wrong. So, this is the thing from
And it should be almost the same. So we
want Hang on. So this one we want
levels and puzzles I
believe. Okay. Also, guys, don't do
whatever the hell they're doing in this
gen chat right now. It's
like whatever.
Okay, so what's happening here? We have
this state that gets passed in as an
integer
pointer
and you get this handle
object. You have to unpack it to a state
dict. And now we don't need this
anymore. We
need puzzles. Levels and puzzles, I
believe.
I'm get Yes.
this
Anyway, is this level's
handle? No, this is
OB. This is not your first time in the
chat and you've asked the same damn
thing
before. If you ask
nicely, maybe you'll get a couple bench
sets. Anything else is extra.
have. Is there a freaking I don't even
think I have the tool for this. I know
in Twitch you can literally just click
on people and be like, "Yes, you did.
Nah, screw that. But thanks for
reminding me. I do need to bench
Look, I mean, at least these type of
trolls are funny,
right? Hey, Captain. What's uh let's say
we get a a binding for Impulse Wars,
huh? We have This is right here. The
last Syon end I've done. I mean, well,
between bet helping and me, all 20 M's
are going to have new API bindings
today.
Yeah, we definitely want
um clean impulse wars. Does that help
with any of the build stuff by the way
or are we still
like we still have to have the thing
basically as like a sub package with its
own cm make and everything?
Need to find time to generate archives
for box studio and we should need to see
make
awesome game
code. What the? There aren't even gifted
subs on YouTube if you don't have a
Am I like missing half the messages?
Bet. It seems like you're responding to
something I'm not seeing.
But yeah, sometimes we do just have to
do a bunch of boring ass
work. I don't have a sub button there
either, man. This is just this is live
research being done.
Like around here we
train we train agents to play games and
we train me to be
jacked. That's what we do. It's training
all day all the time.
If I get binding and build work without
CMake, you can port neural net to
C. Um, possibly
I mean, Captain, I mainly want the thing
to be useful for like training and
experiments. The the C demos are really
nice to chuck on the website, for sure.
Um, I'm more concerned though about
getting the thing not in a damn sub
package and like actually into our
experiment flow, so like we can have
proper sweeps and get proper models,
right?
Wait, why are
you why are you advertising contracts to
YouTube trolls? Like what? What are you
Whatever this was, this is the code that
I needed to base this off
dict for
null. I long check and
cast. All right.
Okay. And then this one is I forgot
this. I just forgot a
line. Is it levels and
puzzles? Yeah, it's levels and
puzzles. All right. So, this is puzzles.
while? Probably just taking a while to
build puzzles, right?
What does shared method do in bindings?
It's if you need to init some objects
that are shared across all ends. I don't
think you have any
um like all your data is small enough
that it doesn't matter if you have it on
every single end. But like for mobile
for instance, the map the pathing data
is 256 megs. So that has to be shared
across all the
instances. I will check out the Q flush
thing as soon as I fix tower climb
bet. Patching
data. Well, it is and it isn't. It's
annoying because right now like I
haven't come up with a way to simplify
the Python API at all. So like the pack
unpack statements are really obnoxious
because the Python API just has a ton of
annoying error checks. But like it's
going to get better. This is basically
V1 of this pure C
um I don't know. This looks like roughly
correct. So I think we're good here.
Yeah, this is fine. It's like unstable,
but we haven't swept it at all.
Yes and no. I'm like my head's like
super fuzzy to be
honest. This like binding work it just
like I get bored and like I just can't
focus. Let me see. Make sure I actually
committed all the files.
this. Wait. Huh?
Unttracked files.
No, it's
fine. I mean, you're not obligated to do
them, but I got them now. It's just It's
not just bindings. That's like only a
day of boring stuff, which is totally
fine. It's just that released is like
three or four consecutive weeks of
boring stuff, and it's just
gh I don't know. I've been playing
Satisfactory in the evenings just like
so I can chill and stop thinking about
this mess. Um it's pretty much just one
of those things where it's you just got
to pace it and it'll be done within a
few weeks and then we'll have our 3
release and literally RL will be a
different field.
Um just from what we have now cleanly
packaged
up. So it's actually like scientifically
it's pretty revolutionary contribution.
Pretty nice.
Right. So, that is all the M's done.
Um, I guess we can maybe do container
stuff for a bit. I definitely don't have
docs in me right now to write
docs, but I think we can probably do
containerization stuff.
this. We're at the cool story, bro, of
people spamming my
Discord.
Mhm. No, I'm thinking in the background
here. So, what I've basically been
trying to figure out in the background
while I've been like doing stuff. So,
right now here, let me explain. We have
base.doccker file. This thing is tiny
and
like do we really
need to have like three different build
stages, you know?
Can't I just like stick everything in
one damn Docker file and call it a
right? Cuz
like this stuff can get cleaned up.
And like the thing is if anything is
going to be different, right? If we're
going to have like different containers,
the most likely difference is going to
be the uh the
Yeah, the way the Docker build is set
up, the multi-stage thing only really
helps if you have the same base and then
different containers on top of that. But
that's kind of unlikely for us, right?
We can always go back to having the
base. But yeah, I think for now we're
going to just paste all the files
together and see what happens because
that's what I usually like to do. And
I'll be right back. Let me use a
restroom and uh grab a drink and we will
hack on this.
branch. So I do have to upgrade drivers
on the host
here if I want CUDA 128.
driver version.
It's not fine is the
thing driver. This is
560. Oh, it's just 6 for this. Yeah.
Okay. Well, what's wrong is whether it's
in it's not in the Abuntu package repos,
I think.
So, like I can do it,
but you have to upgrade your
drivers. Maybe that's fine. Maybe we
just give you an upgrade script.
Yeah, I am going to have to reboot the
stream when I do this and hope I don't
break my system.
128 and like can I just comment? Here's
what we're going to do. We're going to
comment literally everything in here and
then we're going to do like staged
builds.
And we're going to test like one at a
time, which I guess technically is what
the other dockers were for, but this is
just as like this is just fine as Well,
So, like
this Google IO keynote. I don't I
honestly I don't go to any of the like
the big tech
keynotes. Like if something important
happens, I'll hear about it on X.
Otherwise, it probably didn't matter.
anything? Okay, so you only really need
this at the very end.
Let me not delete my container by
mistake.
happening? Well, we are going to do a
bunch of releases for 3L. So, we'll have
all the blog posts come out. I mean, the
thing is like because all of our dev is
public, if you watch the stream, there's
not going to be much surprising, but
it'll still be cool to see how people
react to all the new things where I
mean, we've kind of been quietly
building soda reinforcement learning
stuff for the last few months. And all I
have to do is package it up and it's
ready to
go. The packaging it up takes a
while. Let's go figure out how to update
our drivers in the meantime.
PPA? It's literally just
uh Yeah, this
failed to
solve. Well, let's do this.
Okay, we do
get 570 server
open.
Um, video driver 570 open.
wait am I on a bunt to I'm on
22 or am I on
24? No, I'm on 24.
So, what the heck is wrong with this?
If where this is breaking my system live
on stream, then I will be back once it
is
fixed. We shall see.
So, goal is we do we ship Abuntu
22.04 which is the last Abuntu version
that doesn't have annoying driver
[ __ ] or I mean annoying Python like
virtual M [ __ ]
um
with 20 uh or with 570 driver
compatibility for CUDA 128, which gives
you 50 series card compatibility. Okay.
Yeah. So, it's a little more complicated
than that because on a 50 series card,
if you install 570 like this, if you
install this package, which it says is
compatible on the Nvidia website, you
brick your machine
immediately. If you install the open
one, it works.
I probably should just make a script
that does um you know sets up your host
machine, right?
like we don't need to give you tail
scale and
stuff but like
docker and I could just give you your
docker install
Yeah.
Heat. Come
I'm just trying to make like a basic
setup script. So like we have our whole
setup script for um puffer
boxes, but uh I'm going to add one
that's for
users. We just do a little bit of uh
tooling dev today.
Okay. So, this is where I have to uh I
probably do have to reboot things. So I
will be